if I'm walking around the city I you
know and I see like a bunch of homeless
junkies like nodding off I cross the
street I'm not gonna walk by that I'm
not going to do it I'm not walking by
with my kid and I'm not walking by by
myself like totally you know the risk
reward scenario is just it's just not
there
what do we do about this what do we do
we start arresting the open-air drive
markets you know we used to do that
right so when Giuliani came into office
in New York City in like what 93 or
something like that he started cleaning
up City by doing exactly that he was
just started arresting people arresting
people for selling drugs and it was you
know it was pretty severe and I remember
at the time being like what is this but
um the city turned into a paradise
within about 15 years and it was
spectacular to live there yeah that
sounds very effective it sounds
authoritarian it does sound
authoritarian but I mean I think when
you're talking about a big city when
you're talking about millions of people
living on top of one another who need to
have a safe place to walk